[موسيقى]
ايلون بيري عضو سابق في القوات الخاصه
الاسرائيليه خدمك مستعرب وفي قوات الدعم
خص برنامج للقصه بقيه بشها حصريه تكشف
خفايا عمل وحده المستعربين في
فلسطين يقوم المستعرب بما لا يستطيع
الجندي النظامي القيام به والذي لا يستطيع
حتى الوصول الى هذه
الاماكن المستعرب المتخفي يتحدث العربيه
بطلاق ويفهم الثقافه يمشي في احد شوارع
غزه دون ان يثير اي
شك
يجب ان يرتدوا
كالعرب ويتحدثوا اللغه بطلاقه مع اتقان
اللهجه وعليهم ان يفهموا الثقافه والعقليه
وعليهم ان يفهموا
القران المستعربون المتخفون في العمليه او
في الاتصالات اللاسلكيه يدعون
الملونين اما الجنود الذين يرتدون الزيه
الرسميه فيدعون
الخض
هم العناصر المتخفيه التي تشرع في الهجوم
والخضر هم قوه
الدعم يتم تدريب المتخفين على التركيز في
مهمتهم ويحصلون على الدعم من القناصين وهم
من الخضر او مختصي زرع المتفجرات لنسف
منازل
الفلسطينيين توجد ايضا وحده خاصه داخل
وحده المستعربين يسمونها راس المستعربين
هؤلاء اشخاص مختفون لديهم القدره على ان
يكونوا جواسيس ولديهم موهبه التمثيل
يمكنهم الانتقال من شخصيه الى اخرى خلال
خمس
ثوان المساله هي ان خطه المستعربين وقائد
القوات السريه يجب ان تحصل على موافقه
رئيس الوزراء اذا لم يوافق رئيس الوزراء
فلن تنفذ العمل حرب المدن التي تشنها
اسرائيل عبر المستعربين تواجه وعيا
فلسطينيا باساليب وتضع المستعرب في حاله
خوف وترقب دائم ما ادى الى اصابه العديد
من منتسبي وحده المستعربين بامراض نفسيه
وعقليه وصلت ببعضهم الى الانتحار وفق ما
كشف لنا ايلون بيري وصلت الى وضع بالغ
الصعوبه او شكت فيه على قتل نفسي فعلا
هناك من اصدقائي من قتلوا انفسهم واحدهم
ادخل المستشفى اثر اصابته
[موسيقى]
بالجنون